there was one girl who made headlines
because she sold her bath water yeah and
made like a zillion dollars doing it or
something yeah okay that's the headline
you saw I made a bazillion dollars and
some stupid thing on only fans but then
you look at the statistics the vast
majority of these women are making
nothing yeah and and you think of again
talk about opportunity cost the moment
that you put one picture of yourself up
the moment you present yourself as a
porn girl on the internet that changes
the trajectory of your life what also
you can't do something like that you
can't compromise your dignity yeah
without a belief that knowing it's going
to cost you if if I was looking at porn
in a library or wherever you know in a
coffee shop whatever wherever wherever
even even if I was looking at something
on Instagram that was slightly
inappropriate if someone walks past me
you know I get rid of it